[Music]  kate winslet intentionally did not Bank  Harvey Weinstein when she want her Best  Actress Oscar for the reader in 2009 in  a new interview with The Times Winslet  says not mentioning Weinstein whose  company financed and distributed the  film was absolutely deliberate quote I  remember being told make sure you thank  Harvey if you win and I remember turning  around and saying no I won't no I won't  and it was nothing to do with not being  grateful if people aren't well behaved  why would I thank him when allegations  of sexual assault and harassment against  Weinstein became public Winslet released  a statement condemning his actions she  also told the Times quote the fact that  I'm never going to have to deal with  Harvey Weinstein again as long as I live  is one of the best things that's ever  happened and I'm sure the feeling is  universal  [Music]